it's a friday edition of
p-f-t-o-t and like so many other fridays
the nfl has dumped some news into the
slowest day of the week
surely this is something that could have
been announced on thursday wednesday
tuesday or monday but it comes on friday
now it wasn't 5 p.m
when the news came out it was earlier in
the day right at the beginning of the
day that the nfl announced that tyree
killed the chief's receiver will not be
suspended after an investigation under
the personal conduct policy remember
there were three different aspects of
the personal conduct policy that could
have been violated by hill number one
threats made to the mother of his
children crystal espinal number two
potential child abuse discipline that
crossed the line like you did with
adrian peterson five years ago and then
finally
the circumstances in the household that
resulted in the child being removed by
the government that is something that
under the language of the personal
conduct policy creating an undue risk
for another person especially a child
that could have resulted in some sort of
discipline but the nfl issued a
statement focusing only on the issue of
potential child abuse allegations and
there's some wiggle room in there if
some evidence would emerge in the future
that would allow the nfl to go back and
revisit the case so be it but the bottom
line is after meeting with tyreek hill
for eight hours several weeks ago the
league decided not to impose any
discipline and the thing that caught my
attention
the failure to address in any way shape
or form
the threat the apparent threat and i
don't know maybe
based upon some of the arguments we've
had over words this week maybe somebody
would actually say it wasn't a threat
but when he said you need to be
terrified of me too to crystal espinal
while they were arguing the question of
whether or not a three-year-old boy who
is hill's son respects him or is
terrified of him that that would seem to
be something that at a minimum would
require an explanation as to why
discipline isn't being imposed i've
asked the league to give me some
guidance in that regard because that was
the phrase that was the thing that
troubled so many people when that tape
was first heard the night of the first
round of the draft it caused the chiefs
to send hill away from the offseason
program at the end of round one on that
thursday night back in april so i'd like
to think that someone someway somehow
will be able to explain why that wasn't
even mentioned in the statement because
that to me was the most glaring piece of
evidence that cried out for some sort of
potential discipline but there was no
discipline and there was not even a
mention of that that troubling phrase
that was directed to a woman that tyree
kill pleaded guilty to assaulting back
in 2014 when she was pregnant with the
boy who has been at the center of this
controversy another interesting aspect
of the tyree kill decision
it came without the league
having tyreek hill visit
the nfl headquarters at 345 park avenue
in new york city now usually that
meeting only happens as a precursor to
discipline but we just saw a few weeks
ago ezekiel elliott was brought to the
league office and he wasn't disciplined
so why bring ezekiel elliott and not
discipline him well i think there's a
certain value to having that
face-to-face confrontation conversation
whatever we want to call it with the
commissioner as a way of ensuring that a
guy will stay out of trouble going
forward the league apparently decided
that tyree kill didn't need that type of
one-on-one
double secret probation type of
arrangement that ezekiel elliott seems
to be under or or the other side of it
too and i don't want to go
go too far into the weeds on this it's
possible that if the nfl would have
summoned tyree kill
to the league office and then not
disciplined him it would have been a
bigger deal the reaction would have been
stronger see ultimately it's that
reaction that the nfl is now bracing for
and i've got more on that coming up in a
minute before i get to that point though
another thing that we need to keep in
mind crystal espinal was not interviewed
by the nfl as part of this process that
resulted in no discipline for tyreek
hill the nfl reportedly tried on
multiple occasions to talk to her and
she declined and that's another
flaw
in this process the nfl sets up an
in-house justice system but the nfl has
no power over anyone not employed by the
nfl and if you have somebody who is
willing to participate like the the
former girlfriend of ezekiel elliott a
couple of years ago who was interviewed
six times by the league as a result of
and as part of the process that resulted
in a six-game suspension for elliot if
you have that kind of cooperation it's
easier to come to a final conclusion
that there was a violation espinal
decides not to cooperate so it makes it
harder to come to the conclusion that
tyree kill did
anything wrong again another flaw in
this broader process because the nfl
can't always get the information that it
needs to come to the conclusion that may
otherwise need to come to and that leads
me to the final point for today's pftot
and and let's go back to square one
why does the nfl have a personal conduct
policy
why does the nfl care about the things
that football players do away from the
football field away from the football
facility away from the team
seven months of an off season on your
own time living your life you get in
trouble with the law there's a
resolution of that situation no jail
time probation whatever the case may be
most other employers
would look the other way it's not our
business
the only thing that matters to us is are
you able to show up and work and if it
gets to a point where you can't show up
and work because you're incarcerated
then we have to deal with this
employment issue now look some employers
will blur that line and there are
instances where you need to blow that
line if you're a bus driver you had a
dui probably something that will affect
your ability to continue to drive a bus
but for most employers you have an
incident away from work it doesn't
affect your ability to show up and work
it's none of the employer's business
it's between the employee and the
criminal justice system the nfl decided
as a matter of pr they decided it was
good for business to care about and
actively police the things that players
do away from work and that is something
that had been lingering and lingering
and in 2007
thanks to pacman jones and the late
chris henry the nfl ramped up the
punishment specifically for guys who
have multiple incidents even if they're
never arrested even if they're never
charged even if they've never spent a
day in jail multiple incidents will get
you in trouble more quickly than a
scattered accusation allegation or
confrontation somewhere out in public so
that was the way things worked from 2007
until 2014 then came ray rice and what
happened with ray rice
the nfl initially suspended him two
games based upon the information that
was available to the nfl including a
video that we all saw of
ray rice's then fiance knocked out cold
on the floor of an elevator as ray rice
was standing there apparently trying to
figure out what to do next now
after that two-game suspension was
announced there was some blowback there
was some harsh criticism of the
commissioner for only suspending ray
rice for two games
then came the video that the nfl either
did or didn't have or either knew or
should have known what was on that video
i mean we knew she was knocked out
somehow she got knocked out and then we
see the video the punch that knocked her
out and the nfl essentially ends ray
rice's career and that was the moment
because the commissioner's career was
almost ended in the aftermath of the
emergence of that video remember it was
the day after the start of the 2014
season all hell broke loose and and the
nfl should have been doing a victory lap
after a great week one of action instead
the nfl was reeling for a couple of
weeks the commissioner had to worry that
his
time as the man in charge of the sport
was over and i think at that moment he
decided that he'll never be accused
again
of going too softly on
a player who was accused of doing
something away from work especially when
it involves any type of domestic
violence we saw the personal conduct
policy get beefed up there was the
adrian peterson situation the greg hardy
situation and as of 2014 the nfl was
ready to pounce on any player accused of
any type of misconduct especially
involving family members wives
girlfriends children etc so fast forward
to 2017.
that was when the nfl decided to throw
the book at ezekiel alley based upon
what i believe was flimsy evidence and a
poor procedure not aimed at giving
ezekiel a fair shot at at defending
himself the nfl was determined to
suspend him for six games again the
commissioner was never going to be
accused of going too softly on a player
who got into trouble off the field so
six games period that's it well
what happened in 2017 was two things
first of all the tv ratings continued to
plummet after 2016 when the ratings
first dropped due to the presidential
election on top of that in the aftermath
of the ezekiel suspension what happened
cowboys owner jerry jones went after the
commissioner remember all of that
commissioner was negotiating a new
contract jerry jones was trying to get
that derailed jerry jones wanted to get
rid of the commissioner and so
the pendulum now
which had swung very sharply in favor of
over punishing players now it starts
moving in the other direction and i
think it was a combination of the
assault by jerry jones on the
commissioner and the idea that the tv
ratings are down what do we do to
increase and enhance the tv ratings well
one of the things you do is you make
sure the best players in the nfl are
available to play ezekiel elliott was
gone from the team that is the biggest
draw on national television for 37.5
percent of the entire regular season
when that six game suspension finally
began so i think the nfl decided and
they didn't announce it they never would
announce it but they decided to be more
lenient with players who potentially
won't be allowed to play due to
violation of the personal conduct policy
or
the substance abuse policy because
that's where we first noticed this shift
it was with josh gordon martavius bryant
and randy gregory last year as those
three guys were reinstated after
suspensions of at least a year and there
were reports and there were accounts of
additional issues and problems and
positive tests and under the league's
procedures
they should have been abruptly thrown
out of the game for another minimum of
one year but they weren't see i feel
like the nfl and i firmly believe the
nfl has decided that
it's in the interest of the business to
have the best possible players play
football that that's what results in the
ratings going up and ultimately
recovering from that slump in 2016 and
2017. so that's where they are now and
that's the background and that's why i
believe the nfl which easily could have
suspended tyree kill for four games
eight games 12 games whatever the nfl
has realized that
the potential impact on tv ratings and
thus on the business
of not having hill available to play is
greater than the potential impact on the
business of letting hill play and
dealing with whatever the fallout may be
and really what will the fallout be will
there be protests will there be
demonstrations will there be a call for
a boycott of the nfl because the nfl
didn't suspend tyree kill they've tried
to thread this needle in a way that
enhances the business and you know it's
it's the league version of what we
always say as it relates to individual
teams with individual teams they find a
way to make an excuse for a great player
so the great player can continue to play
the nfl used to be immune from that now
i think we see the league recognizing
we need to have great players on the
field
that if we don't have great players on
the field
and if we're coming up with reasons to
keep great players off the field we are
hurting our business bottom line that's
why tyree kill wasn't suspended and i
believe that if this had happened two
years ago he would have been suspended
just like ezekiel elliott was and if you
flip it if hill did what he did two
years ago
and elliot did what he did this year
elliott wouldn't have been suspended he
would have been the beneficiary of this
realization that it's in the nfl's best
interests to keep great players on the
field and not concoct reasons to
arbitrarily throw them out of the sport
whether it's one game whether it's one
year whether it's one series they want
the best players on the field and that's
why tyree kill wasn't suspended and
that's it for this week's editions of
pft ot we got one more week of pfp ot
only and then pft live is back with a
vengeance on july 29 check us out all
weekend long at pro football
profootballtalk.com and we'll see you
back here on monday
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports